chômage nouvelle augmentation en juillet
la millions 400 mille demandeurs
d'emploi avertissements d'andré bergeron
la libération des prix est insupportable
dans cette période où les incendies de
forêts dans le midi le prix du désastre
c'est le dossier de ce journal mesdames
et messieurs bonsoir la météo politique
et social aura décidément souffler la
vedette à la météo prédit sionnel
pendant cet été
79 mais la veille du 15 août normalement
le sommet des vacances il faut parler
emploi prix rentrée sociale tandis que
se succèdent des déclarations des
ministres des leaders politiques et des
syndicalistes aujourd'hui on a appris
que le nombre des demandeurs d'emplois
avait encore augmenté
on en comptait plus d'un million 400
mille à la fin du mois de juillet cette
dégradation qui s'explique notamment par
le nombre de jeunes à la recherche d'un
emploi se poursuivra jusqu'à la fin de
l'année estime le ministre du travail
robert boulin qui confirmait aujourd'hui
dans une interview à notre confrère
aurores ce qui nous avait dit ici même
la semaine dernière il va accomplir en
septembre un tour de france dans le but
d'assurer le succès du troisième pacte
pour l'emploi des jeunes afin que celui
ci aboutisse dit monsieur robert boulin
a intégré dans le monde du travail
les 450 mille jeunes pour lesquels ce
pacte a été reconduit monsieur andré
bergeron le secrétaire général de force
ouvrière estime que l'aggravation du
chômage est moins inquiétant que prévu
pour l'hiver syndicale c'est la hausse
des prix qui constitue le point le plus
noir de la conjoncture tout à l'heure un
thème 2010 il n'a pas hésité à remettre
en cause la politique de libération des
prix
conduite par monsieur monory ministre de
l'économie et monsieur bergeron a
également parlé du chômage
lorsqu'on compare la situation de
juillet 1978 à juillet 1979
on constate une augmentation de 13%
alors j'entends bien qu'il convient de
manipuler ces chiffres avec précaution
d'abord parce que nous sommes pendant la
période des congés qui provoque quelques
difficultés d'ordre administratif qui
compris dans l'assurance chômage
et puis je pense qu'il faut attendre
pour regarder ce que donnera
l'application du nouveau système
d'indemnisation des chômeurs
vous savez que ça jouera à plein à
compter du 1er octobre mais enfin je dis
ça avec d'infinies précautions et
beaucoup de prudence
il semble que l'évolution du chômage
soit moins grave qu'on l'avait pensé il
ya quelques mois on a beaucoup parlé du
prix du pain or on a voulu faire
confiance
on a vu le résultat c'est vrai dans des
quantités d'autres endroits
alors nous ne demandons pas qu'on ait
recours à des systèmes policiers
autoritaire mais enfin il faut
surveiller
or c'est ce qu'on ne fait pas
suffisamment on a réduit il y a quelques
mois de 20%
les effectifs des services de la
concurrence et de la consommation
on ne peut pas se contenter de faire
appel au sens de la responsabilité tout
le monde sait bien notamment dans les
périodes de vacances que beaucoup
s'engagent dans la course au profit
ce matin parlant là monsieur bergeron ne
connaissait pas les résultats du
commerce extérieur pour le mois de
juillet ils sont connus maintenant
l'alourdissement de la facture
pétrolière qui met en péril les
équilibres de nos échanges avec
l'étranger est un autre motif
d'inquiétude pour l'économie française
en juillet pour la seconde fois de
l'année
notre commerce extérieur a été
déficitaire comme en juin un déficit
légèrement inférieur à 1 1 milliard de
toujours à antenne 2 midi de ce repère
général de force ouvrière s'est défendu
de vouloir jeter de l'huile sur le feu
de la rentrée syndicale
il a affirmé qu'il n'était pas question
d'une alliance avec la cgt pour créer un
front syndical contre la politique du
gouvernement
nous ne voulons pas globaliser les
problèmes nous entendons rester fidèles
à notre ligne de conduite à savoir
discuter les rémunérations les
conditions de travail dans le cadre des
conventions collectives c'est-à-dire que
nous ne croyons pas à l'efficacité de
décision à caractère global comme on en
a connu et non mais je risque de ce dont
je vous parlais monsieur bergeron je
suis désolé de vous couper mais c est ce
que vous êtes prêts à vous accorder ne
changerons pas notre politique c'est à
dire c'est à dire que nous ne ferons pas
nous ne pratiquons pas l'unité d'action
avec la cgt
monsieur françois mitterrand fera lundi
à anglet près de biarritz des
propositions pour relancer l'action de
la gauche
actions je cite qui devrait remettre un
mouvement d'union indispensable de la
gauche a affirmé ce matin monsieur
propre un secrétaire national du parti
socialiste comme une conférence de
presse sans dévoiler le contenu de ces
initiatives mais ce peu près indiqué que
les socialistes étaient favorables à
toutes les possibilités de rencontres
aussi bien avec les formations de la
gauche avec les syndicats nous entrons
at il expliqué dans une phase politique
nouvelle car pour la première fois le
pouvoir d'achat des français va reculer
monsieur georges marchais secrétaire
général du parti communiste sera
d'inviter d'antenne midi après midi
demain en 8 c'est à dire si je compte
bien mercredi 22 le départ du paquebot
france ou plutôt comme il convient de
dire maintenant du paquebot norway
puisque c'est ainsi qu'ils appellent est
retardé
il y a deux raisons tout d'abord celle
de sécurité à cause de mauvaises
conditions météorologiques
les remorqueurs qui devait assister le
navire au milieu de l'année prochaine ne
pourront pas intervenir avant demain
matin
et puis deuxième raison les ouvriers de
la réparation navale du havre ont bloqué
les cuisses françois 1er celle qui
permet de relier les bassins de la zone
industrielle où se trouve amarrée le
paquebot au port même du havre en somme
ils ont fermé la voie de sortie
le point de la situation par jean claude
renoult 500 à 1000 personnes ont
manifesté ce matin devant la
sous-préfecture du havre pour s'opposer
au départ de l'ex paquebot france des
élus locaux dans le maire communiste de
la ville monsieur duroméa qui reste
persuadé que le gouvernement peut encore
convaincre l'armateur norvégien de
revenir sur sa décision
les travailleurs des chantiers navals et
des marins aussi qui ne se résignent pas
au départ définitif du navy et moins
encore à la perte d'un million d'heures
de travail au profit des chantiers
allemands
population du havre elle n'a pas répondu
massivement à l'appel de la cgt
beaucoup semblent considérer que les
syndicats livre un baroud d'honneur et
que le norway de toute façon partira
pour l'allemagne
mais dans la journée les mauvaises
conditions atmosphériques ont prêté main
forte aux syndicalistes
un vent du sud ouest de force 7 à
empêcher le des doublages des amarres et
de leur côté les équipages des
remorqueurs qui doivent assister le
paquebot ont annoncé qu'il refusait
d'intervenir avant demain matin 9 heures
dans l'après midi enfin la cgt décidé
d'occuper pour une durée limitée
lécluse françois 1er qui relie le quai
de l'oubli au port propre manguy la
police après avoir demandé aux métallos
d'évacuer s'est retirée sans intervenir
si les cluses reste bloquée bleus
n'auront et ne pourra pas passer voile
admiral's cup c'est le championnat du
monde des courses au large en plusieurs
épreuves chaque bateau un équipage
composé de plusieurs personnes cette
année il ya hélas des victimes
dix neuf hommes d'équipage sont déjà
portés disparus après le naufrage de
plusieurs voiliers lors de la course des
du fastnet une mer déchaînée des
dizaines et des dizaines d'appels de
détresse en mer d'irlande sa course du
fastnet a déclenché la plus grande
opération de sauvetage en temps de paix
que la marine britannique et d'une
montée
les hélicoptères de la royal navy ont
recueilli cet après midi une vingtaine
dé 90 concurrents qui ont fait naufrage
le bilan pour l'heure est de 19 disparus
de deux morts mais de nombreux corps ont
été vus flottant à la surface de l'eau
le voilier morning claus et joris
l'ancien premier ministre britannique a
lancé un appel de détresse son
gouvernail cassé
ces équipages de trois bateaux français
et a rompu la chariotte heures et
bonaventure ont été secourus par des
bâtiments de la flotte britannique
ce soir encore les hélicoptères
continuent de survoler la mer d'irlande
afin de repérer les naufragés un saint
vith ferait de la situation est
redevenue presque normale dans les
bouches du rhône et dans le var mais la
nuit dernière plusieurs foyers
importants subsistaient encore dans le
gard et l'hérault à proximité de nîmes
200 hectares ont brûlé
mais les opérations de noyage du feu ont
réussi ce matin à l'aube dans le
vaucluse sur le versant nord du massif
du lubéron
un autre feu celui de six verges a été
noyé par les canadair dans les roues un
foyer de murray en pleine activité
aujourd'hui
au milieu de la journée sur la commune
de pardailhan où l'on a vu brûler 400
hectares de chênes verts et de
châtaigniers là le feu s'est propagé sur
un fonds de 5 km les pompiers avaient
une tâche particulièrement ardue mais
les canadairs ont encore permis de
reprendre comme le dit la situation dans
tous les départements de la provence
durement éprouvée par les incendies une
surveillance attentive demeure en place
des milliers de pompiers et de
volontaires veillent sur les foyers
encore chaud en espérant que rien ne
viendra attiser les braises dans
certaines localités des habitants
avaient dû fuir et n'ont rien pu sauver
du feu ils ont tout perdu par le feu ils
sont totalement sinistrée un reportage
sur place de jean-louis lesaint
il est venu dans marc duval on met alors
à une vitesse vertigineuse est venu en
rien de temps nous l'avions dessus nous
avons eu juste le temps de monter dans
les voitures de partir aucune parole
là ils sont solides et canadair si on a
vu des canadairs oui entre le garlaban
et nous je pense qu'on aurait arrêté le
feu mabri les canadairs et les pompiers
de l'eau lourde l'eau
alors qu'est-ce qu'il a eu comme dga
exactement moi les dégâts j'ai tout
perdu
la maison complètement la maison anéanti
celle de papa papa est brûlé au
troisième degré
les épaules le dos le ventre et le
visage et la 92 ans je sais pas comment
il va s'en sortir
alors comment comptez-vous être
indemnisé moi je suis assuré maintenant
vous dire que mon père ont intégralement
ça je ne le crois pas tout serait
certainement
quelque chose ce n'est pas la valeur ni
drame propriété ni de la maison puis
tout le linge que nous avons dans une
maison depuis 25 ans 30 ans qu'on amasse
jamais on me rendre à tout ça vous avez
perdu aussi beaucoup d'animaux oui j'ai
perdu tout le poulailler avait 50 canal
une trentaine de 35 pour le 31 de lapins
des pigeons sept chiens un perroquet en
fait tout ça c'est un détail nous avons
la vie sauve c'est l'essentiel
mais en fait c'est une grosse perte moi
j'ai trois enfants et j'ai la petite qui
est beaucoup trop matiz et parce qu'elle
vient ici et le pleurent le taciturne et
les noms les bons coups traumatisé à
diverses reprises vous avons dit que les
feux n'ont pas tous été accidentel que
certains ont été allumés par les mains
criminelles
rappelez vous cet appel reçu samedi par
téléphone au quartier général des
pompiers du var
la voix anonyme nous vous l'avons dit
lisez ceci nous avons mettre le feu
partout alors se développer en bien les
parties de la provence une sorte de
psychose et dans la petite cité de
mornas dans le vaucluse
on a créé des milices anti pirates six
courses du pyromane est bien réelle à
mornas la forêt n'avait pas brûlé depuis
30 ans en un mois 300 hectares se sont
envolés en fumée
la simultanéité des feux ouf qu'il
s'agit de l'oeuvre d'un incendiaire
non
et tout comme plusieurs foyers et on a
retrouvé certains éléments qui nous
qu'on pensait que le feu ne s'est pas
mis tous les canaux mois on peut partir
sous des poutres d'alain tas de sable ça
paraît difficile qu'ils se mettent eux
tout seuls n'y a pas des mégots ya pas
de paix sans avant-hier le conseil
municipal a décidé d'ouvrir la chasse
aux incendiaires
il a constitué quatre brigades composées
de 16 volontaires chacune
si vous la frappez vous le ramenez de
l'état gendarmerie vous n'y allez vous
chicaner tous les feux et toujours des
colliers les gendarmes ont signalé
d'évolution personnelle huard mais pas
d'armes
on voulait ramener quelques d'accord
entendu d'accord ces personnes sont
bénévoles en voiture et en moto elle
surveille les 3000 hectares de la
commune
à l'aide de leurs jumelles pour ce
campeur la solidarité doit jouer pour
combattre les pyromanes
y'a pas que ce que les gens de mornas ou
où les gens de province qui doivent
défendre cette forêt nous autres c'est
un poste qu un patrimoine national si on
veut aller par la cua mais qu'est ce que
vous voulez je vous dis moi je suis pour
pour moi c'est normal que j'ai fait ce
que j'ai fait c'est tout et mon dieu
j'ai pas fait grand chose j'ai
simplement aider à éteindre le feu avec
la création de ces groupes de
surveillance un danger existe les
pyromanes risque d'être soumis à la
vindicte populaire
quelles sont les conséquences de tous
ces incendies il est difficile de le
dire déjà avec précision il ya les
conséquences écologiques incalculables
pour l'avenir de la montagne et de la
forêt provençale
il ya les conséquences économiques
financières d'abord la facture il faut
payer les moyens mis en oeuvre le chlore
fake
les 4000 hommes à peu près dépêchés sur
place il y à l'effort demandé aux
communes pour l'intervention à la
protection tout cela donnera un bilan
très lourd le chiffre exact on le
connaîtra seulement dans quelques temps
ci tentait qu'on puisse jamais le
connaître d'ailleurs disons que le coût
de ces incendies est extrêmement élevé
montauroux une petite commune du var
près de grasse 13 cents habitants trois
mille hectares
plus de la moitié en bois et en forêt un
patrimoine qui coûtent cher plus d'une
centaine d'hectares brûlés il y a
quelques jours par mesure de prévention
la commune a mis sur pied un corps de
sapeurs pompiers volontaires
coût 3 % de son budget a nommé trois
permanents et tous les grands comptes
comment vous être énumérées en tant que
pompier volontaire à l'intervention les
chercheurs je suis fils de bûcheron ou
un deux trois fois la semaine
ça s'est réglé et pour des durées des
fois longue durée un jour un jour demi
des fois deux jours et alors il ya la
fatigue bien sûr et puis le manque à
gagner
ça représente combien seulement quelques
années vous pouvez le chiffre et on a
souvent qu'à gagner il me fait perdre
j'ai jamais vraiment calculée au centime
près mais disons qu'entre paru l'or en
solo faisons coutord registre il faut
ajouter à ce manque à gagner les frais
entraînés par des mesures de prévention
telles que la création de sentiers
forestiers l'organisation de tournées de
surveillance prises en charge par le
budget communal soit au total près de 10
% de ce budget très peu de communes du
var ou des bouches du rhône peuvent
supporter une telle charge en mesure de
prévention également nous avons établi
un réseau d'adduction d'eau avec de
nombreuses tares l'apesa les poteaux
d'incendié qui ils coûtent fort cher
comme vous le savez je peux évaluer a
également eu en moyenne dix mille francs
par an la dépense en adduction d'eau est
le point le plus important que je tiens
à préciser c'est que notre corps de
sapeurs-pompiers comporte un grand
nombre d'employés communaux et bien à
longueur d'année je vois mes services
municipaux qui sont désorganisés
par les incendies rarement les a sortis
dans la commune mais le plus souvent les
incendies en dehors ce qui est normal il
ya une solidarité à la lutte contre le
feu alors qu'il doit payer l'état où le
contribuable local
l'état prendra en charge dans le cadre
du plan orsec les moyens mis en place
quatre mille hommes 250 véhicules
militaires
une facture difficilement chiffrables
pour le moment les départements comme le
département du var le plus sinistré
devront aussi plié une lourde facture le
coup en en finance si vous laissez plus
simple et bien je me faisais la
réflexion hier que nous étions des gens
qui coûteront cher en ce sens que je me
suis rendu compte hier après midi qu'on
les pensait 8000 francs l'air à peu près
ça donne une petite idée de la situation
au total 1100 nouveaux bien entendu en
gros 80 % du budget du service
départemental d'incendié passe au feu de
forêt qu'il s'agisse de frais fixes
l'instruction est un majeur et c'est ou
alors de frais et de frais variables le
moment des interventions les les
salaires les sens la casse
c'est assez important je pense que cette
année ces frais variables dû aux feux de
l'été vont tourner autour de 5 millions
à cela il faut ajouter le coût de
l'heure de vol des canadairs 15000
francs
depuis le début de l'année les pilotes
ont déjà effectué quinze censeurs de
lutte contre le feu et puis l'an dernier
le coût du reboisement était de 10000
francs lecteurs près de cent mille
hectares ont brûlé en france cette année
la ville en un milliard de francs par
qui ont fumé le ministère de
l'agriculture a prévu l'an prochain une
augmentation de son budget pour la
prévention et l'intervention contre le
feu mais cela permettra-t-il d'éviter
une nouvelle marée rouge
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'hectares ravagés malveillance mais
aussi imprévoyance négligence manque de
moyens sans parler des pyromanes dont il
était question tout à l'heure à
marseille jean louis le sait n'a pas
invité monsieur chartrand responsable
régional de l'aménagement forestier
oui léon monsieur chaudron est
exactement chef du service régional
d'aménagement forestier c'est à dire
qu'il dépend du ministère de
l'agriculture
alors messieurs chartrand vous avez
survolé la région provence côte d'azur
nelly
aubeterre les incendies cette année ont
déjà ravagé une grande superficie mais
pourtant - selon vous que ce que l'on a
annoncé il ya quelques jours
oui j'ai effectué l'estimation des
surfaces brûlées pour les deux
départements des bouches du rhône et du
var et je crois qu'on peut annoncer le
bilan provisoire avec les chiffres
suivants environ treize mille hectares
pour les bouches-du-rhône et 12000
l'hectare pour le département du var il
faut ajouter à cela environ 2000 pour
les alpes-maritimes et environ 500
hectares pour le vaucluse ce qui nous
amène en gros entre 25000 à 27 milles
hectares beaucoup allemande
c'est beaucoup mais ce peut être pas
tellement puisque nous avons eu déjà des
années qu'ils atteignaient des
superficies qui valente
je vous citerai par exemple l'année 1962
pour lequel le bilan définitif était de
29 mille hectares pour en 64 il était de
28 mille évidemment il y a eu des années
catastrophiques qu'en 1970 où la
provence alpes côte d'azur a payé un
tribut de 42 mille hectares aux feux de
forêt alors maintenant que peut-on
espérer raisonnablement comme moyen de
prévention l'avenir d'écouter la
prévention s'établit en de deux façons
différentes d'une part l'éducation
plutôt l'information du public
et puis l'équipement du terrain en ce
qui concerne l'éducation du public le
ministère de l'agriculture s'attache
chaque année à faire une campagne le
mieux possible en dépensant évidemment
le moins d'argent possible puisque la
publicité coûte cher et puis sur
l'équipement du terrain et bien je crois
qu'il faut continuer l'oeuvre entreprise
savoir l'équipement des périmètres et
accessoirement dans les départements
sensibles
la constitution de tranchées pare-feu
deux chemins nouveaux et de réserve
d'eau pour permettre plus facilement aux
pompiers d'intervenir en tout cas la
cause on ne peut pas envisager de
s'organiser ici comme dans les landes
non le problème est absolument différent
les langues se sont constitués par un
pays plat et surtout par une forêt qui
normalement rapporte de l'argent son
propriétaire la forêt landaise produits
du bois et produits de la gêne en
provence côte d'azur la forêt rapporté
autrefois du charbon de bois et du bois
de chauffage
aujourd'hui il ya encore quelques
résineux malheureusement ils ont été
décimés par la maladie l'otan maritime a
été détruit presque complètement par la
cochenille mathier caucus depuis 1950
c'est à dire que du point de vue
écologique il est nécessaire de
reconstituer la ferai mais cappone et
économiquement on pourrait à la limite
son passé ou économiquement bien sûr
mais le rôle de la forêt en provence
alpes côte d'azur c'est surtout un rôle
de protection et un rôle d'accueil pour
l'homme
la région est une région touristique
elle reçoit en était un grand nombre de
vacanciers et la forêt poursuit
vacanciers est tout de même
l'environnement un environnement
privilégié avec le soleil et les plages
et surtout une toile de fond
sensationnel pour les gens qui vivent
dans ce pays
danse à cette saison mais alors comment
comptez-vous maintenant vous y prendre
pour reconstituer la flore 1 eh bien je
crois qu'il faut on peut pas en temps ça
deux moyens vient d'abord la nature qui
est bien fait et qui permettra pour une
part à cette forêt de se reconstituer
naturellement vous savez que les
résineux ont des graines très légère qui
sont disséminées par l' incendie qui
dans la germination est facilitée par la
cendre et une part de ceux de ses
peuplements brûlé se reconstitueront
naturellement on verra apparaître les
semis d'ici un an deux ans peut-être
trois ans et puis il ya les feuillus les
feuillus comme les chaînes qui sont bien
protégés par leur écorce le manchon
isolant du chêne-liège est absolument
classique et bien s'ils vont reverdir à
l'automne ou sinon si vraiment la partie
aérienne est morte
eh bien ils rejetteront dessous c'est la
forêt se reconstituera en partie de ce
que vous n'êtes pas un peu trop
optimiste quand je suis peut-être un peu
optimiste bien sûr mais vous savez que
la forêt méditerranéenne est une forêt
très ancienne elle a toujours brûlé
depuis la plus haute antiquité et que
les reboisements vraiment sont tellement
coûteux qu'on en fait relativement peu
et qu'il faut compter beaucoup sur la
nature en présentant l'actualité ce soir
j'ai le sentiment d'être injuste
j'aurais peut-être dû vous parlez pour
commencer de cette effroyable
catastrophe qui a ravagé lundi
la rupture du barrage de notre vie sur
la côte ouest du pays
c'est sans doute la plus grande
catastrophe de ce type en un siècle
la presse indienne situe le chiffre des
morts entre 5000 et 25000 rappelez-vous
en décembre 1959 il ya vingt ans la
rupture du barrage de malpasset dans le
midi près de fréjus avaient fait 420
morts c'est plutôt un drame affreux un
deuil national naturellement hors jeu
les biens dits pour l'invs entre 5000 et
25000 et en plus de l'énormité du
chiffre il ya cette terrible
imprécisions car en vérité on ne sait
rien cela s'est produit il ya plus de 48
heures et les premiers secours ne peut
arriver qu ce matin car les eaux
continuaient à déferler et les pluies
diluviennes empêcher la progression des
sauveteurs ont survolé la zone sinistrée
en avion par point d'hélicoptères et
ceux qui revenaient disait on a vu des
morts dans l'eau sur l'eau dans ces
espèces de bouillonnement qui recouvrait
des villages combien villages engloutis
5 houssin il n'y avait pas de matériel
de secours il n'y avait pas de téléphone
de campagne quand le premier détachement
de policiers par vince était ce matin
sur les lieux de la catastrophe les
survivants leur demandèrent avec
angoisse qu'apportez-vous ils
répondirent rien nos bâtons d'agents de
police nous n'avons rien d'autre que
cela je sais que nous avons en france
nous ennuie nos problèmes
je sais que l'un de ces loin je sais
qu'à la télévision nous n'avons pas
encore d'image acheminer des cameramen
sur place n'étant pas pour le moment de
plus urgent est de 5000 à 25 mille
victimes
c'est affreux au sahara la mauritanie et
l'algérie en renouer des relations
diplomatiques qui avaient été rompues en
1976 c'est une des conséquences de
l'accord de paix signé à quelques jours
entre la mauritanie et le front
polisario sur le terrain pourtant la
tension continue de monter
après la prise de contrôle par le maroc
de la région de tibhrine garbia partie
du sahara occidental administré jusqu'à
ces jours derniers par la mauritanie
alors que les notables de cette région
sont arrivés à rabat où ils vont prêter
serment d'allégeance roi du maroc hassan
ii
le front polisario a lancé aujourd'hui
une mise en garde très sévère aux
marocains allant jusqu'à annoncer que
les hommes du polisario ferait désormais
porter leur coup jusqu'au coeur même du
maroc annonce faite à paris par la voix
de monsieur ibrahima kim ministre des
affaires étrangères du polisario
seuls 2 de par son attitude
intransigeance faire la fête une
solution politique
faire la fête aux solutions pacifiques
et l'hélice aucun autre choix qu'ont
solution militaire
le front polisario en tout cas quant à
lui à partir de cette situation créée
par l'intransigeance marocaine
intensifiera ses opérations militaires à
l'intérieur du maroc et les intensifiera
le plus loin possible et le plus
durement possible intensifiera sa lutte
légitime défense
donc à l'intérieur du maroc et dans les
parties de notre pays occupé par les
criminels marocain
la réaction marquée les violences selon
l' agence france-presse une personnalité
politique proche du gouvernement
chérifien a déclaré les dirigeants
mauritaniens ne prennent pas de gants
pour renverser leurs alliances
le maroc lui non plus n'en prendra pas
et appliquera vis à vis de son allié de
la veille la même politique du fait
accompli c'est le cliquetis des armes
iran la situation s'aggrave aujourd'hui
encore des heurts violents ont opposé
militants islamiques et partisans de la
gauche laïque
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
manifestants ont défilé pour clamer leur
appui à la est à la tr min et sa
conception purs et durs de la révolution
islamique
plusieurs organisations de gauche ont vu
leur siège saccagé par les commandos
estat irlande le dixième anniversaire de
l'intervention militaire britannique en
irlande du nord aura été marquée par une
flambée de violences malgré les mesures
exceptionnelles de sécurité qui avaient
des mises en place
les heurts violents qui ont opposé hier
à belfast les catholiques favorable lira
aux soldats et aux policiers
britanniques ont fait plusieurs dizaines
de blessés
voitures et autobus en flammes barricadé
jets de pierres l'irlande du nord a
retrouvé ces derniers jours la violence
et la sève d'une par l'ira et les
activistes catholiques ont saisi
l'occasion de ce dixième anniversaire de
l'arrivée des troupes britanniques pour
relancer leur campagne d'agitation
politique et d'attentats armée mais
aussi les protestants menacent de
reprendre leurs activités terroristes
l'un des principaux groupes protestants
lui des as qui dit être forte de dix
mille membres a sommé le gouvernement de
renforcer la répression contre les
catholiques
sinon ont-ils dit nous nous chargerons
nous-mêmes d'éliminer physiquement l'ira
enfin pour la première fois depuis dix
ans un journal anglais est allé jusqu'à
suggérer que la grande-bretagne retire
ses troupes de l'irlande du nord qui
doit être estime cet éditorial libre de
décider soi-même son propre destin
en allemagne le circuit automobile le
plus célèbre celui du nürburgring en
général ce sont des grands champions qui
disputent les compétitions les plus
difficiles et donc les plus belles mais
depuis quelques temps la main moyens et
emmène sa famille le dimanche pour voir
ce que cela pourrait donner s'il n'y
avait aucune réglementation de la
conduite automobile
un reportage de michel meyer
nürbürgring un nom magique pour tous les
passionnés de course automobile c'est
celui de l'anneau de vitesse qui fut
durant plusieurs décennies le champ clos
de toutes les grandes compétitions
ce haut lieu des sports mécaniques est
cependant de plus en plus délaissée par
les professionnels en le juge trop
dangereux
mais ces équipements de sécurité sont
sévèrement critiqué par les pilotes de
grand père
désormais les bolides de formule 1 ne
rugissent plus au nürburgring et les
courses qui s'y disputent n'attire plus
les foules de jadis
normal ces courses non plus le niveau et
la classe des grandes confrontations
cette dévaluation du circuit ne l'a
cependant pas disqualifié pour tout le
monde il est en effet devenu chaque week
end le décor des rencontres et des
carmes est des plus extravagantes
entre fous du volant amateurs un peu
inconscient disons de défonce motorisés
et drogués de la vitesse
prix d'accès à cet anneau de libération
de défoulement et de vitesse 12 deutsch
mark exigé par des gardiens vêtus comme
des agents des pompes funèbres
ce qui ne semble pas d'ailleurs
impressionné des candidats au suicide
peut être trop enthousiastes pour être
superstitieux
camaraderie chaleur humaine c'est ce que
recherche ici notre interlocuteur c'est
ce que recherchent les impossibles
fangio du nürburgring pour qui la
sobriété reste apparemment une vertu
trop ennuyeuse pour être vécu
avec ou sans bière au corps la fête de
la vitesse comme ans
c'est là que l'épicier de cologne se
prend pour niki lauda et le mécanicien
en caoutchouc pour gérard larousse c'est
là aussi que les chauffeurs de taxi se
libère et kas en trois tours de piste
les bouchons psychologique de toute une
semaine de travail au ralenti
à l'extérieur du ring la partie de
campagne se poursuit alors qu'en bordure
de piste et avant l'action
les adeptes de ce défoulement estivale
rêve d'approcher les exploits des
coursiers des grandes écuries de
l'automobile
mais il ya loin de la condition de
badauds à celle de champion et les
dérapages ne sont pas toujours aussi
contrôler qu'on le souhaite
de même que des dégâts qui font la joie
des carrossiers locaux mais aussi des
petits chats dick qui bien placé dans
leur virage difficile et fier de l'être
ils le disent d'ailleurs ouvertement se
délecte de la malchance des autres
en vérité les gourmands de tôle froissée
sont bien les seuls à ne pas être déçu
par les embardées du cirque qui est
désormais devenu le nürbürgring
pour le tiercé de demain dans le grand
handicap de la marche à deauville voici
les pronostics de pierrette brès d'abord
le 14 cachemire prins ensuite le trois
pains d'épicés le 9 weight bold le 5
croque-monsieur mange beaucoup dans ce
handicap le 4 paires bagatelle de sept
windy 4 le 6 lamielle le cese guildford
de résume 14 3 9 5 4 7 6 et 16
ce qui nous mène tout droit à la météo
voici le temps valable sur la france
pour la journée de demain un temps plus
frais et variable venant de l'océan et
de la mangeoire à passer peu à peu le
pain chaud et orageux qui se maintiendra
encore toute la journée sur le midi et
l'est du pays les vents d'ouest seront
assez fort près de la manche
ce soir c'est hervé claude qui vous
présentera des dernières informations
n'oubliez pas demain antennes 2010
présenté par daniel bilalian
et si vous le souhaitez nous pourrons
nous retrouver demain soir ici même à 20
heures bonsoir